quand j'étais étudiante en architecture
j'ai appris des tas de choses certaines
étaient utiles et d'autres les témoins
et dans ma quête de sens et dames
je suis allé à la rencontre d'un homme
qu'on surnommait l'architecte du peuple
cet homme sert hassan fathy un
architecte égyptien est probablement le
plus grand architecte humaniste de notre
siècle
il me disait j'ai mis vingt ans à
parvenir à oublier tout ce qu'on m'avait
appris à l'école
il a construit des villages en terre
crue en egype avec juste de la terre et
de la paille
il m'a fait découvrir qu'on pouvait
simplement en étant à l'écouté des
personnes de leur mode de vie de leur
façon d'être de leurs besoins simples
quotidien et bien larchitecture pouvait
naître de sa naturellement sans effort
c'était effectivement très différente de
tout ce qu'on m'avait appris il me
disait il faut avoir la sensibilité
il disait pour construire une maison
pour un pêcheur tu observes le
déploiement de son filet et la maison et
l'a naturellement ces quelques années
plus tard que j'ai eu l'occasion dans
des circonstances plutôt dramatique de
mettre en pratique tout ce que j'avais
appris avec lui c'est et en 2002 en
afghanistan la guerre contre les taliban
venait juste de se terminer
des milliers de réfugiés revenait des
camps du pakistan il arrivait
dans leur village qu'ils étaient
dévastés par la guerre et en mars avril
2002 2 important tremblement de terre
ont dévasté toute la région nord de
l'afghanistan
donc en plus de faire face aux suites de
la guerre et d'avoir à reconstruire
l'ensemble de leur vie eh bien ils ont
dû se retrouver avec leurs leur logement
complètement détruit alors il y à des
ong magnifique qui reconstruisent après
ce genre de catastrophe
j'avais la chance d'en faire partie et
voilà la mission qui nous a été proposé
il fallait reconstruire 5000 logements
en moins de six mois
pouvoir les terminer avant l'hiver on
avait 260 $ par logement et on avait
avec nous donc à loger 25000 personnes
dont environ dix mille femmes et enfants
pour nous aider à construire parce que
les hommes n'étaient pas disponibles il
avait en charge à eux de mettre en route
les cultures de réparer les canaux
d'irrigation de remettre en route toute
leur vie pour pour que l'île au moment
où l'hiver arrivera et bien ils puissent
nourrir leur famille
dans ce contexte là ce qui m'a décidé le
plus à partir ces deux défis principaux
le premier défi c'était qu'il fallait
reconstruire évidemment de façon
résistant aux tremblements de terre et
on était dans une région très pauvre de
l'afghanistan où les maisons étaient
construites en terre crue pratiquement
essentiellement avec très peu de bois
parce que le bois étaient rares et donc
des standards de construction en terre
crue parasismiques et bien il en
existait pas dès lors qu'on voulait
renforcer une construction pour qu'elle
résiste tremblement de terre alors on y
apporter du béton
dans ce contexte là il n'était pas
question d'apporter du béton pour une
raison simple pas seulement financière
on n'avait que 260 $ par logement et
donc de toutes façons c'était pas
possible mais aussi pour une raison
éthique et c'est ce qui me motivait le
plus quand on importe un matériau dans
un lieu où ce matériau n'est pas
disponible
on rend dépendants une population et
finalement on crée des besoins qui
n'existaient pas donc le défi le plus
immense et et technique il fallait
résoudre ce problème avec les matériaux
disponibles localement et le deuxième
défi il était humain est là en fait il y
avait eu une expérience en 1998 après le
tremblement de terre de rustaq en
afghanistan et les ong avaient construit
avec beaucoup d'efforts et beaucoup de
bonne volonté
huit mille logements en terre crue
parfaitement réalisé eh bien ces
logements ils sont toujours inhabité
inoccupés pourquoi parce qu'en fait ils
avaient été conçus par des bureaucrates
qui avait complètement oublié de se
poser la question de comment vivaient
les gens quelle était leur quotidien de
quoi ils avaient besoin
alors il avait organisé ses maisons en
ligne droite avec des rues
perpendiculaires parallèle comme dans
une ville américaine alors que
finalement c'est des gens qui avaient
besoin d'une intimité en dehors de leur
maison et qui n'arrivait pas la trouver
là donc ils ne se sont pas du tout senti
concerné et personne n'est venu habiter
dans dans ses 8000 logements qui sont
encore à une ville fantôme
de quoi donc me motive et complètement
pour cette mission qui a commencé par
des des obstacles évidemment le premier
obstacle c'est qu'on sortait à peine de
la guerre il y avait encore beaucoup de
danger il fallait
une semaine entière pour arriver jusqu'à
kaboul en avion humanitaire
les avions de ligne ne fonctionnait pas
encore de kaboul il fallait dix heures
de route en passant par un un col un
tunnel de 20km à 2000 mètres d'altitude
un tunnel qui ne fonctionnait que dans
un sens ce qui fait qu'en fait il
fallait s'assurer qu'on donc il
fonctionner dans un sens un jour sur
l'autre
il fallait donc s'assurer qu'on arrivait
le bonjour parce qu'en plus il y avait
un couvre-feu à 8h et que si on passait
le couvre-feu eh bien on risque est
réellement sa vie sur toute la route il
y avait encore des mines partout
certains des mineurs étaient déjà passés
pour marquer les mines d'une croix rouge
mais tout n'était pas encore trouvé il y
avait très peu de communication puisque
en fait les réseaux communication
n'était pas encore remis en route il n'y
avait pas de téléphone portable y avait
uniquement de communication par radio
pas d'internet
et puis le temps le temps six mois c'est
très court pour à la fois concevoir
réfléchir analyser les réalités locales
bien comprendre comment les gens
vivaient aller les voir se documenter
comprendre l'organisation sociale
comprendre aussi
quels étaient les matériaux disponibles
et comment on pouvait les utiliser
trouver des solutions techniques trouver
les artisans locaux qui pouvait
fabriquer certaines parties qui
n'étaient pas réalisés par les habitants
eux-mêmes
et puis évidemment mettre en oeuvre ces
solutions
et puis 260 dollars c'était bien peu
pour construire des maisons
évidemment 260 dollars c'était pour
fournir les matériaux qui n'étaient pas
disponibles localement en particulier le
bois mais il a fallu rogner surtout
jusqu'au moindre cloud pour pouvoir
rentrer dans ce budget là et obtenir
l'ensemble des matériaux qui était né
sait
r et puis on avait avec nous évidemment
pour construire avec 260 dollars il faut
là où il faut la collaboration des
habitants s'étaient donc de
l'autoconstruction les gens construisent
eux-mêmes alors avec la terre crue il
savait très bien comment faire il n'y
avait pas de souci par contre on avait
que des femmes et des enfants avec nous
lorsque les hommes étaient au chant je
suis allé voir le chef du village
l'épicentre en fait de ce tremblement de
terre
le village était totalement détruit et
le chef du village m'a accueilli j'avais
besoin de savoir quelles étaient leurs
priorités quels étaient leurs
problématiques pouvoir les entendre
pouvoir poser mes questions
il m'a accueilli un petit peu durement
comme les guerriers afghans savent
l'être
il m'a dit après m'avoir écouté pendant
10 minutes m'a dit écoutez si les
maisons que vous allez nous construire
sont identiques à celles qu'on construit
celle qu'on a toujours fait
eh bien on n'a pas besoin de vous par
contre on a besoin de vous pour
construire des maisons qu'ils
résisteront au prochain tremblement de
terre donc le défi là ils revenaient
réellement un défi technique
alors je suis allé chercher au loin la
fois dans ma mémoire de d'autres
réalités du monde que j'avais rencontrée
mais aussi dans des livres des
conférences des conférences auxquelles
j'avais assisté
et puis j'ai découvert là par exemple au
cachemire des constructions qui avait
incroyablement résister à un très fort
tremblement de terre
ces constructions étaient bien en terre
crue et elle avait résisté pour une
raison assez incroyable c'est qu'en fait
le les parties de bois qui la
constituent et lui avait donné de la
flexibilité
on dit toujours que pour résister un
tremblement de terre
la seule et unique solution c'est de
rigidifier l'ensemble de la structure
or là c'est le parti totalement inverse
qu avait été pris en permettant de
donner à cette structure toute sa
souplesse et bien on lui permettait
d'être de résister à un mouvement qui
est finalement un mouvement très très
fort très violent et horizontale alors
là j'avais ma solution parce que ces
techniques utilisées très peu de bois
malgré tout il en fallait mais pouvait
donc résoudre le problème de de notre
village en afghanistan et l'a donc en
mettant des des ceintures horizontale à
la base au sommet des renforts de bois
dans les angles différents éléments des
linteaux avec des portes et un petit peu
plus importante de part et d'autre des
fenêtres et bien on est arrivé à avoir
quelque chose qui qui tenait la route
tout cela a été conçu dans les deux
semaines de préparation de ce projet il
faut savoir que pour un architecte la
conception d'un projet pour un certain
temps habituellement
hélas en deux semaines parce qu'on avait
que six mois il a fallu tout réfléchir à
la fois la conception de l'organisation
des espaces est aussi technique
et puis il a fallu négocier et ça
c'était pas le plus facile négocier avec
les donateurs négocier avec l'onu qui
était en fait l'organe qui surveiller la
reconstruction de l'ensemble de
l'afghanistan parce qu'en fait il avait
conçu des maisons modèles et il voulait
qu'on se conforment à ces modèles mais
ces maisons modèles avait un problème
c'est que elle fonctionner dans un dans
un lieu isolé par exemple au milieu d'un
champ effectivement on pouvait les
construire par contre dès lors qu'il
s'agissait de reconstruire dans des dans
des villages existants assez dense et
bien là le problème était différent
parce que les personnes était toujours
propriétaire de leur parti de maison
même si elle était en
trois quarts des truites e n'imaginais
pas du tous ses expatriés et allait
construire une maison ailleurs ils
étaient propriétaires de leur petit bout
de terrain de leurs de leurs maisons
existantes et évidemment la seule
solution était de reconstruire à
l'endroit même de leur maison et donc
les il a fallu négocier ça avec l'onu
pourquoi parce que les donateurs
souhaité que chaque bénéficiaire puisse
être facilement identifiable qu'on
puisse mettre un nom sur chaque maison
qui avait été reconstruite pour vérifier
qu'elle avait bien été réalisés alors si
on laissait faire les gens sans cet
ordre là ça leur était difficile de
vérifier
alors on a réussi à négocier quelque
chose on a réussi à leur faire accepter
qu'en fait il donnait à chaque
bénéficiaire la même quantité de
matériaux la même quantité de poutres la
même quantité de portes et de fenêtres
et que avec cette quantité là chaque
habitant avait la possibilité de
reconstruire ce qu'il souhaitait ou bien
une pièce à l'étagé vient d'agrandir son
rez-de-chaussée ou bien de le rénover
simplement sa maison on a vu des
situations comme celle là où sept
habitants avaient choisi de construire
une pièce à l'étagé sans sans même avoir
fait un escalier ni un accès mais ils
avaient prévu que pour l'année suivante
et bien y aurait il y aurait là un accès
et puis il y avait finalement les
architectes qui organisait tout ça on
était deux l'un pour mettre en place le
projet et l'organiser en préparer les
bases et puis l'autre pour passer les
six mois sur le chantier a dirigé les
travaux et pour y arriver
un seul architecte pour 5000 logements
est allé sur un grand territoire avec
des villages qui étaient accessibles
uniquement à cheval là ça a été toute
une organisation
alors l'idée est venue donc de former 25
techniciens 25 personnes qui pouvaient
donc représenté l'architecte sur un
groupe de 200 maisons
c'était déjà plus
râble et puis il y avait une règle c'est
qu'à chaque partie de la construction
les habitants étaient dans l'obligation
de faire appel aux techniciens
dès lors qu'on arrivait sur un aspect
technique important donc on avait décidé
de trois grandes étapes de la
construction sur lesquels le technicien
était indispensable et à ce moment-là
appelé pour surveiller la qualité du
travail qui avait été réalisé puis il a
été fait une maison modèle pour former
ses techniciens pour leur permettre de
savoir comment commencer ses aspects
techniques particuliers pouvaient être
mis en oeuvre
il était là donc pour surveiller fur et
à mesure et voilà donc au bout du compte
vingt-cinq mille hommes femmes enfants
ont réussi à reconstruire leurs maisons
à reconstruire leurs vies en moins de
six mois
et des situations comme celle-là il en
existe partout dans le monde et chaque
jour une nouvelle catastrophe nécessite
une nouvelle mobilisation et chaque fois
même dans l'urgence il ya la nécessité
de trouver des solutions humaines
techniques durables qui ont simplement
besoin d'intelligence d'ingéniosité et
surtout d'engagement
mon professeur assane fatri me disait il
faut se révolter ne jamais s'habituer et
moi je souhaite à tous les jeunes
architectes à tous les jeunes de vivre
leur métier avec passion avec engagement
et de toujours se révolter pour
construire le monde qu'il souhaite
vraiment merci